[Music]
hello all we at stl are delighted to
support the fdth europe conference 2022
as platinum sponsors
the world's largest fiber summit
europe's connectivity landscape is
witnessing rapid change needless to say
fibre-powered highways will underpin
future technologies ensuring the
inclusion of beings who are still
unconnected
now is the time for everyone to build
full fibre networks for a digital and
sustainable europe
stl has been at the forefront to enable
gigabit broadband across europe with our
continuous endeavours to accelerate
fibre dense 5g
our advanced optical networking
solutions help telecom operators and
ftth players roll out networks faster
more effectively and cost efficiently in
the most sustainable manner
we will be showcasing our 5g ready
end-to-end solutions of booth po4
we look forward to meeting you and
collaborating to tackle the new industry
challenges and emerging opportunities
together
we wish you all the best at the event
and we will see you soon thank you